the news went out last night from nfl
media ian rappaport reporting that a
deal was closed that would send receiver
antonio brown from the steelers to the
bills antonio crown responding on
instagram by saying fake news and it all
went downhill from there overnight
plenty of reporters disputing the report
that the deal was closed i was told it
was never close now here's the problem
when you've got a bunch of different
moving parts and you have to placate the
steelers and you have to play kate brown
and you know maybe it's close between
the steelers and bills but it's never
close between the bills and brown and
it's it's a huge multi-pronged mess so
the cat got out of the bag prematurely
bottom line is big cat we thought we'd
spend the entire show talking about
what's exactly going on it was all
resolved within the first five or ten
minutes of our first hour on nbcsn
second hour on nbc sports radio the idea
that the bills were in it but now
they're not they've said so themselves
their gm brandon bean issued the
statement we inquired about antonio
brown on tuesday kept talks open with
steelers we had positive discussions but
ultimately it didn't make sense for
either side as greater players antonio
brown is we have moved on and our focus
is on free agency so
the antonio brown era
is over in buffalo
it's over
and it's crazy that it was even uh an
era for five hours there or whatever it
ended up being six hours because the
minute it was it broke at 12 o'clock
last night and antonio brown then got on
his instagram and said fake news that
should have been the sign right there i
know that obviously you know guys can
can maybe not be clued into everything
that's going on but the steelers like no
team is going to trade for antonio brown
without sitting down with antonio brown
talking to his agent being like hey is
he going to buy in here is he going to
be someone who wants to be here because
we saw what happened last year when he
didn't want to be somewhere
so that right there was was it the fake
news when antonio brown gets on
instagram and comments fake news to me
that was when this entire deal was dead
because if antonio brown isn't 100
committed to his new team the new team
has there's no reason for them to trade
for him none whatsoever it will only end
up hurting them and not helping them
and i think if he and rappaport made any
mistake here because maybe it is true
maybe a deal was close who knows there's
enough smoke there that maybe there was
a flicker of flames somewhere at the
bottom of this but you can't just assume
it's like any other trade it's not like
any other trade big cat you've been all
over this notion for a few weeks now
antonio brown is acting like a free
agent you can't just ass oh hey the
steelers and the bills have a deal so
it's done no it's not done not unless
antonio brown says it's done so they can
be close on compensation between the
steelers and the bills that doesn't mean
antonio brown's on board with it and
most of the reports that have emerged
over the last hour made it clear that
that was the the sticking point brown
doesn't want to play for the bills
period so the the deal is not going to
happen and in what other in other than
quarterback what other player in the nfl
other than antonio brown can stand up
and basically say i've got a no trade
clause even though he doesn't
okay so now that we're in hour two my
brain has woken up here and i'm starting
to have some racing thoughts up there in
this old noggin of mine
was this all done by the steelers to
basically anchor the negotiation and say
hey antonio brown we could send you the
bills and you don't want to be on the
bills so then when it's the raiders or i
don't know the jets where whoever may be
the next in line
they already have said
the bills were at least discussed and
now you have to go and put on a smile
and say i want to be here and do all
those things because you had a moment
there there was a moment last night
where it was going to be antonio brown
in buffalo kind of scaring him
because he doesn't want to be there and
i love the city of buffalo so i think
buffalo is getting dragged unfairly here
but it's clear he doesn't want to be
there and the steelers essentially
anchored this negotiation and now
they'll have antonio brown go along with
whoever they you know get to the trade
table with and antonio brown say the
right things and basically be a good
trade partner in this entire uh free
agency that he's created out of thin air
i think you're onto something because
look they did this kind of thing a
couple of years ago they've softened him
up right
they've scared him with the prospect of
sending him to buffalo they've backed
off even though they don't have to back
off and now when they do trade him to
another team he's going to feel more
inclined to say okay i'll do it because
here's what happened back in 2017. right
after the facebook live fiasco in the
locker room after they beat the chiefs
in the playoffs and right after they
lost to the patriots in the afc
championship game there was a stream of
negative reports about antonio brown at
the time and they were coming from
people who are close to the steelers i
was convinced the steelers were putting
all that out there to make him look bad
and basically to scare him a little bit
and then what happens within six weeks
after that he signs a new contract when
there was no reason for him to sign it
then he could have let it play out a
little bit more but i think they
softened him up in late january early
february of 2018 before he or 17 before
he took that long-term deal same thing
going on here softening him up giving
him that threat showing them what they
could do if they want to and now maybe
he's going to be more amenable when the
time comes to sit down and work out a
deal to oakland or wherever it is
although other than oakland i don't know
what the option is i don't know whether
the team wants him unless there's
somebody out there that's been lurking
that we don't know about but now every
team now now the steelers can have
antonio brown be amenable to every team
they can he can walk up and say look i
will i will play for this team because i
don't want to go play in buffalo i i'll
tell you mike it takes an hour for this
brain to get going but buffalo's closed
now that that's a problem no i know if
the door to buffalo was still open
then then that's a stronger point but i
like the idea that they used this to
kind of scare us to what they could do
and now he's now that he's played the
veto card once like maybe the next time
it's going to be harder for him to say
you know you can't say no to seven
different teams you can say number one
you can't say no to the second one and
you definitely can't say no to the third
one and there was a moment last night
where antonio brown was sitting at his
house seeing those reports and probably
you know frantically called his agent
and said
am i really going to buffalo and so
those moments the next the next trade
partner in line is not going to be as
bad as what he thought buffalo would be
again i love i love the city of buffalo
and it's unfair what what people are
saying about buffalo but i'll tell you
mike it takes an hour for this brain to
get warmed up but when it gets cooking i
just uncovered the entire thing i just
connected all the dots and i think we're
done here right that's the show
so we should just so that's just it we
just end it now and have the mika motto
auction on for the next 50 minutes all
right
here's the question though who does he
want to play for the only team that he
has shown any clear inclination or
desire to play for is the 49ers and
they're out of this so where does he
want to go where do you think if you
were antonio brown who would you want to
play for well so why why are the 49ers
out of it let me ask you that first
they've said they're out of here out of
it okay and of course yeah it would it
wouldn't be the first time that a
general ranger head coach has told us
something other than the truth but let's
assume they're out of it let's assume
they don't want him
where do they go from here where does
brown want to go from here well i i
still think i just want to wrap up that
san francisco point because if antonio
brown keeps saying he wanted to go to
san francisco and it's the only place he
said he wanted to go wouldn't it make
sense for the 49ers to say no we're out
of it to try to bring down the trade
value you know what i mean the steelers
then have to come back to the 49ers like
this is the only place he wants to go
will you do a deal with us instead of
the 49ers saying oh let's go do a deal
let's give him everything and the
steelers have the upper hand with that
negotiation i think he wants to go to a
quarterback that is going as much as he
bashed big ben i think he wants a
quarterback that is established and he
knows he'll be good and so i wonder
about the raiders i don't know if he
like i think he could be sold on the
raiders because john gruden has been so
nice in in his uh praise for antonio
brown but i i honestly think he does
want to play for the patriots he will
not play for the patriots but that's
where he wants to go i wouldn't be
shocked if he wants to go you know he
throws out throw out all the good
quarterbacks in in the nfl he wants to
go there
and uh he's not gonna he's not gonna get
to pick like you said he's not gonna get
to pick every single spot here he he
said no to to buffalo or however it went
down but the next one he's gonna have to
say yes to i'm saying though i think the
49ers i think you're you're taking that
for face value i feel like the 49ers are
also playing a little game here
john lynch the gm of the 49ers said last
week that the team never inquired about
antonio brown kyle shanahan has said
that they're not interested in brown but
you're right maybe maybe the way they're
trying to set this up maybe this is the
ultimate game of poker between the 49ers
and the steelers that the 49ers wait for
the steelers to call them and say is
there anything you can do here i mean we
can't find a trade partner and this is
the only team he'll say yes to what will
you take this guy and what will you give
us for him so i think that's a
possibility but that runs counter to the
idea that they are trying to scare him
straight by almost trading him to
buffalo and now they can unload him on
another team whoever that other team may
be but i don't know other than the
raiders i don't know who makes sense if
the 49ers aren't in it and and sims
yesterday on the program and he's close
with kyle shanahan and he made it clear
that he hasn't talked to shanahan about
this but his explanation was look
shanahan's got bigger fish to fry he was
10 and 22 his first two seasons he
doesn't need to throw in this antonio
brown wild card at a time they're trying
to figure out how to keep guys healthy
how to win some games how to compete in
the nfc west of course the response
would be well if you have antonio brown
at 100 capacity that's going to help you
compete in the nfc west so i don't know
maybe they should revisit their lack of
interest now that it looks like this
thing's starting to go down the drain
for the steelers
all right so i've thrown out a couple
different names in hour one i threw out
the browns i threw out the bears uh let
me throw one more out there it's way
it's the state he went to college in the
detroit lions
wouldn't you think they would make a
call because matt patricia is sitting
there saying
no year one didn't go so well we know
what matt stafford can be with an elite
wide receiver you know calvin johnson
and what he did with him
why wouldn't we go try to make a splash
with antonio brown reinvigorate this
entire you know fan base with it with a
splash like that in the trade market and
then have matt patricia focus on the
defense and matt stafford and antonio
brown be able to light up the scoreboard
i don't think it would work
but it's an interesting name to throw
out there and i also love the big j
journalist thing to do is to pick where
he went to college or where he went to
high school and then just assume he's
going to go to the nfl team that's
closest to that
well and here's the thing about the
lines and i like that i like that and
i'd be lying if i said i haven't done
that from time to time the lions are
trying to instill that patriot way
between bob quinn the gm who used to be
with the patriots and matt patricia who
was with the patriots for 15 years and
the thing about the culture they're
trying to instill there and it's the
same as new england you have to check
your ego your individuality your your
inclination to maybe not be on time all
those things have to be forgotten and i
don't know that antonio brown is ready
to change he said within the past week
or so they got to play by my rules so i
know when chad johnson played for the
patriots they tried to strip away who he
was and it made him less of a player and
he was willing to do it at that point in
his career i don't know that antonio
brown is ready to have that fundamental
change into who he is and i think it
would be too much of a shock for him in
new england or in detroit he just
doesn't realize it even if he wants to
play for the patriots he doesn't realize
what it would be like and how it would
fundamentally change him so i don't
think the lions want him i know the
patriots don't want him and you know the
question is who wants him and who does
he want it it may be a very small
universe of teams and
there's still this possibility big cat
that the steelers wake up and say you
know what we're just keeping this guy
and antonio you can either play for us
or play for no one and if you choose to
retire we'll take that 11.4 million in
signing bonus money we've given you that
you haven't earned yet and by rule you
have to give it back to us if you choose
not to play
it's a good point eventually one of
these deals will not be good enough and
the the steelers are not going to just
take any old deal right i mean
what do we think the going rate is right
now for antonio brown what has been the
rumored compensation because
i i could see it like you just said the
steelers get to a point where like we're
not gonna trade this guy we can't trade
him for what you're offering and we'd
rather just deal with it and try to get
him back out on the field for us than
trade him for absolutely nothing to
someone else
yeah if it was just three years 39
million which is what's left on his
contract none of it's guaranteed that's
an attractive contract but he's made it
clear he wants a new contract he wants
guaranteed money the market now is
around 17 million per year for receivers
he's going to want something that you
can massage the numbers and we're
getting very close to the time of year
where there's plenty of number massaging
and new money and average per year and
all this stuff where you can say i've
got the best contract of any receiver in
football he's going to want to be able
to say that with a straight face so
we're looking at a significant raise
that someone's going to have to commit
significant guaranteed money that
someone's going to have to commit and i
don't know who out there is willing to
give something significant to the
steelers give something significant to
brown and run the risk that this guy is
going to continue to be the same pain in
the butt he's been for the steelers for
the last however long it's been we don't
know how long it's been we just know it
all came to a head the last few months
so that's what makes the and i've always
thought this is going to be a difficult
deal to do and i think the one thing
we've learned over the last nine hours
of real time this is going to be big cat
a difficult deal to do
yeah and and you just showed that
graphic
if a team offers a third round pick for
antonio brown why would the steelers say
yeah
like what what would be
i don't know a third one picks okay but
antonio brown
picked for martavis bryant think about
this they got a third round pick for
martavis bryant
and antonio brown is at some point the
steelers might just sit him down and say
listen you do this to yourself because
what you did was you went public with
everything you went on instagram live
you didn't show up for week 17 you
basically cut us off of the knees for
any future negotiation we can't get the
value back for you
that we expect a player of your caliber
and they just say listen you did it
yourself so either you play for us or
you don't play at all because we're not
going to trade you for a third round
pick all right we got to take a break
we're over time here there's one little
wild card in all this though and i have
a feeling i don't know this i have a
feeling ben roethlisberger has already
made it clear to the steelers it's
either him or me next year which i think
is is another reason why the steelers
are so anxious to get this done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports